I'm reporting tonight from Las Vegas
where almost four months after the
deadliest mass shooting in US history
there are still so many unanswered
questions it's bizarre we made repeated
requests to Vegas PD for one law
enforcement representative to update us
on the investigation on air of course
into killer Steven paddock and they
provided us with only this it's a terse
email from the public information
officer Laura Meltzer that reads in part
no one from the LVM PD will be
participating in any interviews about
the 1 October incident for the Ingraham
angle well thanks well while some news
that new information has trickled out
over the last few days I say most of it
where I really read through it called
through it only raises more questions a
lawyer for the police department says
charges may be coming soon against
someone else and it's stemming from what
officers discovered in that Mandalay Bay
hotel room on October 1st remember
inside they found padic dead this is 47
guns thousands of spent cartridges and
other equipment had all those bags that
he somehow was able to get into the
hotel by himself his girlfriend Mary Lou
Dan Lee seer there who claims no
foreknowledge of the shooting spree has
admitted now that her fingerprints are
probably on some of the ammo because get
this she helped load the cartridges I
have other information on her - you're
not going to want to miss that coming up
federal court documents that were just
made public because the press was
pressing for them revealed that the FBI
as early as October 6th as just five
days after the shooting believe that Dan
Lee was the most likely person who aided
and abetted Steven paddock so where is
she now
and why don't we have more information
on this woman and why were they so eager
so early on to say patek acted alone
after reporters pressed for the contents
of search warrants in the aftermath of
these killings the federal government
did release 315 pages of material in the
last few days but the Las Vegas police
apartment has basically gone radio
silent citing concerns about the ongoing
investigation well now a federal judge
is mulling the request from The
Associated Press in the Las Vegas
review-journal
to force the release of search warrant
affidavits and other evidence such as
inventories of what was obtained from
their searches very important there are
many questions that remain unanswered
the paddock home was ransacked before
authorities could return that was on
October 10th again why wasn't that
locked down and what happened to hey Suz
Campos the Mandalay Bay security guard
who exchanged fire with Patek and was
injured we saw him on Ellen once and
then never again and where is all the
surveillance video of Patek gambling at
the casino checking in with all those
bags and of anyone entering or leaving
his hotel room why would they release
that and why given all that we're now
learning again were authorities so quick
to declare this a lone-wolf shooting
with no accomplice complices right now
we believe it's a sole actor a lone wolf
type actor was a sole shooter there is a
no further threat that we're aware of no
immediate threat I want to emphasize we
believe Patek is solely responsible for
this heinous act now authorities should
do what's necessary of course to protect
the integrity of the investigation
that's a no-brainer but they've gone in
the other direction I think trying to
lock down as much information as
possible they're extremely defensive
over there at the Las Vegas police
department and we're big supporters of
the police as you all know and we know
by the way what happens in the absence
of real information conspiracy theories
you see them all over the internet will
they incubate and then they end up
coming to life distrust and resentment
builds among the public and of course
the victims families we're gonna hear
from one of the shooting survivors
coming up but that absence of
information the vacuum
it's totally unconscionable the biggest
the worst mass shooting in US history
now the same game of hide the ball
happens in politics as well we've seen
scenarios were both government bodies
and journalists end up revealing or
reporting only part of the story of
course the part that they need to
advance around agendas or cover you know
or cover their own posteriors the
public's interest isn't served in either
case either when the government does it
or when journalists do it now look at
what the press has been doing just in
the past week okay
they've been fat shaming Donald Trump me
how a guy who eats McDonald's and white
chicks with all those diet cokes and it
never exercises is in as good a shape as
you say then do much but Donald's too
many thugs do you think it won't pull
them at it any borderline obese can you
characterize that as an excellent help
for the president his weight I think
he's at 239 right that's it seems I
think it's just shy of obesity and
speaking of waists while they're trying
to push the narrative that the president
is physically unfit for the office or
mentally unfit they keep insisting that
he's a racist that's the other stunt
they're pulling all the while they
advance countless non stop such
emotional immigration sob stories you
have this Christmas which I guess in the
back here mine you're thinking well this
is the last at this point in time
Christmas with my husband who's about to
have to go to Mexico what what do you
what did you do with your family by the
way that went on for about 10 minutes
well how was your Christmas how are they
how do you feel those types are really
hard-hitting interviews I have a
question for CNN have they ever done
such an empathetic interview with
victims of illegal immigrant crime or
maybe an expose of the american workers
displaced by cheap immigrant labor I
mean this I don't think I've seen
interviews with with presidents or heads
of state that went on as long as that
interview we just saw tiny snippet there
it has the band of jackal circle on the
President on the most ridiculous matters
such as the ones we just discussed major
stories and developments both domestic
and international are given short shrift
North Korea what's happening to Middle
East Oh
China the trade whoa now when I talk
about that I'm talking about Trump's
waist and and his BMI well no wonder a
recent Pew survey indicates Americans
think that they have the most biased
media in the world only 21% of Trump
supporters think the US media is fair I
can't believe it's that high and only
55% of those opposed to the president
think the media is fair I've seen worse
polls than that by the way who are the
new John Chancellor's out there David
Brinkley Peter Jennings who remember
them they actually reported on real
stories it wasn't all about them and
making their moment in the press of
course our own Bret Baier he's a
respected professional who plays it down
the middle but other than Brett who else
is out there at the same time our
government both the executive branch in
Congress they hide too much from us as
well to all those senators resisting the
Trump agenda on trade and immigration
for instance what are the big donors
demanding and how has that changed your
public position on these major issues
isn't that something you'd like to know
and who actually writes these bills that
are hundreds and even thousands of pages
long and that are filled with all sorts
of goodies inserted at the last minute
are these like 24 year old staffers are
there other people I mean is there a
collaboration of people who sit around
writing this junk this is the swamp at
its worst no wonder they don't know want
us to know what's going on and as for
the White House I'd say open up as much
as you can without hurting the delicate
process of governing the bsh before s
hold meeting I like to call it that way
that Trump had were those congressional
leaders on immigration that was
excellent and I hope we see more of that
the American people want facts and they
want answers not the big brush-off
especially from those entrusted to serve
the public good whether it's the police
the federal government and public
servants and the press they call
themselves public servants too at the
same time many people I guess they
probably want to hear less from
politicians certain politicians like
Jeff Flake or Cory Booker
whose pitiful preening before the
cameras reminds us of why we elected
Trump in the first place and that's the
angle